uh candace owens
has been refused a covid test because
the um operator of an independent covid
testing clinic said you're not getting a
test here because you've been a purveyor
of covert disinformation and immediately
uh candace owen says is this woman
racist now why is this interesting this
is interesting because candace owens has
been
a very popular voice on the right as a
black conservative supposedly you know
it actually seems this all might be a
character a grift to make money but
let's let's imagine that it's real
and candace owens has been a loud voice
saying all of this stuff about systemic
racism all of this stuff about the right
being racist the real problem she has
said over the years
is that the left so quickly goes to
assuming anything they don't like is
racist
i'm going to play a video for you here
in which candace owens immediately says
maybe the woman denying me a covet test
is racist okay so she's doing it before
getting into that i want to mention
there's been a small controversy over
the last few days with candace owens
where she had to cancel an event because
she was suddenly ill
but has been insisting that it's not
coronavirus
and yet here she is talking about how
she's actually been seeking a
coronavirus test
which obviously raises questions about
why if you definitely don't have the
virus why are you getting tested for the
virus but she was denied a coveted test
we will look at why in a moment and here
she is immediately saying maybe the
woman denying me the test is racist i
thought candace we weren't supposed to
immediately say the motivation must be
racism for something that we don't like
take a look this thing maybe koben's
racist maybe susanna's racist i don't
freaking know i don't know the last time
is the woman who denied her the test the
democrat refused the black person
service and said it's because i don't
like your thoughts and ideas we were in
the jim crow era but here we are
and we're actually in aspen colorado and
susana wants to know that she will
google you this virus is not political
but she's googling people that are
signing up for tests to make sure that
their politics align with susannas can
you imagine like
yeah well okay so
dear god um
so so the the the argument here that uh
candace is making is
it's conceivable that i was denied a
covet test because
susannah is racist now here's the email
that was sent from susanna
to candace subject appointment
cancellation notice
i've just learned of this testing
request and as the owner of this
business i'm going to refuse this
booking and deny service
whoa wait a second isn't this what
conservatives want
a business owner to decide who do i want
to serve and who don't i want to serve
susanna wrote we cannot support anyone
who has proactively worked to make this
pandemic worse by spreading
misinformation politicizing and
discouraging the wearing of masks and
actively dissuading people from
receiving life-saving vaccinations
candace owens has done all that that's
accurate
the only other local testing option is
the free kiosk by city hall they mail
their tests to texas and have
inconsistent result times do not take
appointments so it's walk-in only midday
weekdays in their back alley my team and
myself have worked overtime to
exhaustion unpaid and underpaid this
last year spending our own capital to
ensure our community remains protective
it would be unfair to them and to the
sacrifices we have all made this year to
serve you susanna that is the free
market of ideas that candace owens
supposedly
um supports and it is a business owner
deciding what is best for themselves and
even though candace owens has made money
for years and years saying look at all
these democrats immediately finding
racism the racism is seeing the racism
and yet in the first five seconds she
says
maybe susanna herself is racist what a
pathetic
hypocrite and remember it's almost
certainly all a grift we'll have more on
this on our instagram find us there at
david pakman show find me on instagram
david.pacman
one of our sponsors is curiositystream
the only subscription streaming service
that focuses exclusively on
documentaries if you love documentaries
the way i do you're missing out if you
don't have a subscription to curiosity
stream i love it for one reason it has
the biggest best selection of
documentaries that you'll find anywhere
including the newest popular ones that
everybody's talking about and most of it
is stuff you really can't find on other
streaming services last month they added
a ton of great new documentaries to the
library one i watched is brimstone and
glory
about a pyrotechnic festival in mexico
random but fascinating curiosity stream
is giving my audience 25 off meaning you
can subscribe for just 15 bucks a year
not a big price tag relative to the
hours and hours of enjoyment i know you
will get from curiositystream just go to
curiositystream.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video